the mandalorians collision course with
boba fett this season will reveal a past
rematch between tomorrow morrison's
adult bounty hunter
and the jedi who ruined his life with
this papa jango
on kamino obi-wan kenobi hello there
setting up ewan mcgregor's solo spin-off
series
[Music]
[Laughter]
welcome back to boo stars
the only thing better than an episode of
wild speculation about the mandalorian
season two is a halloween themed episode
of wild speculation about the
mandalorian
season two or as i call it season boo
i am the heavy microphone breathing
wild heart thieving copia stevieing
host of this show tommy beck told her
this is rogue theory the only show that
brings you the devilishly nerdy hot
takes
on the topics that are to die for
with me today is the nosferatu of new
rock stars skerrick
eric voss
hi everyone happy halloween
um hopefully you're not too scared
because there's lots of reasons to fear
in this year yes yes there are this is a
very real rip from the headlines
halloween as i say
uh coming up next we have friend of the
show comedy writer
host of the crush fictionally podcast
hopefully she doesn't get crushed really
in real life
but it's fine to have a crush on her i
suppose kimberly trung
kimberly hello how are you i'm good
thanks for having me yeah
all right i like your ears those are
very nice
uh and we are thrilled
to welcome to rogue theory my comedy
buddy a man that i first nerded out with
in a car ride to long beach comic-con
and thus a nerd relationship bloomed
say hello to my friend and fellow comedy
nerd tom
michelson hello tom how are you hello
everybody thanks for having me i
and this is my first time a new rock
star so i wanted to make sure that i was
dressed up but also this is my halloween
costume tommy hold on
oh i'm john wick
yes you are you look outstanding i i
should have worn a costume i definitely
should have won
[Laughter]
i believe eric you have some things
you'd like to say oh uh yeah i i
couldn't go
a full out with my costume because you
may notice i'm wearing this amazingly
cozy perfectly fitting
this is the way mandalorian shirt this
is actually
from new rockstar's new official merch
store that we're launching
you can find it at newrockstarsmerch.com
and this
mandalorian shirt is our limited edition
collectible latest obsession
offer it's uh we're only making a
limited amount of these you gotta get
them before they come back
uh i just love this it's nice to have a
very comfortable actually good nerd
fitting shirts that you know i don't
have to like
a brave a hot topic to go try to find um
and
a nice little bonus when you buy this
particular shirt you can add on at check
out a special custom shout out that
tommy and i will include on screen in
episodes of wikileaks our mandalorian
after show next episode's coming
tomorrow after
the episode premiere so just get on this
help support me rockstar so one day you
know we don't have to scream at you
about
bang energy drink in the middle of every
video cool that would be yeah what
you know but i'll never stop raving
about ball trimmers so manscape you're
safe with me
search that merch but good luck getting
those t-shirts because i've got my
minions on it and they're ordering them
as we speak i'm ordering them in all
sizes
i've got a planned weight loss and
weight gain this year of hundreds of
pounds so i'll be down
i'll be all the way down to a child's
large and all the way up to a male
7xl which is the only way to sleep in a
tent
uh and wear a tent with you at all times
all right
let's get spooky with it and also sci-fi
with it and a little bit of fantasy
with a dash of western season two of the
mandalorian
is premiering in a matter of hours the
success of season one on disney plus
has led to the announcement of other
star wars spin-offs including an obi-wan
kenobi series that is now in production
with ian mcgregor uh hello
many believe this upcoming mando season
will introduce us
to one of these spin-offs so please my
friends
pitch me your theories on how the
mandalorian season two will set up
future star wars titles eric we're going
with you first my man
yeah yeah tommy you may remember how
last week we started exploring this idea
on our first episode of wikileaks and uh
the idea that i pitched is that
mando's encounter with boba fett this
season could lead to a kind of flashback
with boba fett's encounter with obi-wan
kenobi you know back when he was a
little
little
wee boy on uh during attack of the
clones when they were both on kamino
but i think the mandalorians collision
course with boba fett this season will
reveal a past
rematch between tamara morrison's adult
bounty hunter
and the jedi who ruined his life with
this papa jango
on kamino obi-wan kenobi hello there
setting up ewan mcgregor's solo spin-off
series so
what do we know about this kenobi series
other than you know it's gonna be dope
well uh it's gonna be reportedly set 11
years before
a new hope so that would be after order
66 or revenge of the sith
and uh after obi-wan left baby luke with
uh
i think it was joel edgerton and uh
nexium bonnie yeah right i think those
are the two
um and i think we're about to learn that
ben kenobi didn't spend several years
just
in a desert creeping on luke from the
other side of beggar's canyon learning
how to imitate a crate dragon roar to
scare off some jawas
that's not what he's doing this guy's
got he's full of adventures
and uh obi-wan and boba fett have only
crossed paths as i mentioned on screen
when bubba was a kid he was escaping
with his dad on slave one from kamino
but i think adult boba fett didn't show
up until empire strikes back
and that would be after obi-wan's death
on the death star though
george lucas did insert boba fett back
into a new hope and one of the restored
editions
in that scene with uh han solo and jabba
the hutt um
but i do think we're gonna see what
adult boba fett was up to on tatooine
during the years obi-wan was there and
the way
rebels kind of gave us an amazing
tattooing rematch between obi-wan and
maul
i think we're gonna see a live action
rematch set in those early years
with the sun boba fett still angry over
the jedi
slicing off his papa's head on geonosis
and he seeks out mace windu mace windu
was
thrown out a window on coruscant and
then instead he traces down one of the
few jedi left kenobi on tatooine
and i think this is going to be a story
told by bella that to mando
as i speculated in some of the trailer
breakdowns we do know mando is going to
return to tatooine
maybe run into the remnants of jabba the
hutt's criminal network that could lead
him to boba fett
who if you remember is a clone and he
may be able to give
mando answers on why that guy dr
pershing who was wearing a camino patch
was studying the child in episode three
of season one
and since mando is also seeking answers
about the jedi boba fett he knows all
about the jedi he's gonna tell us that
story about how when he as a younger man
tried to hunt down one of the few
remaining jedi kenobi
who lived not too far from here just on
the other side of the canyon and we know
baby yoda is over 50 years old
so he might have been present for that
fight between kenobi and boba fett maybe
the early years of baby yoda will be a
subplot in this kenobi series
and i think the big twist of this
mandalorian season 2 will be
baby yoda communing with a force ghost
that only the child can see just off
screen mando's confused as hell what is
this kid smiling at
but we just hear you and mcgregor's
voice saying hello there old friend and
then we cut to black
wow wow
that is a lot to process very exciting
for me
i uh i love uh just
the idea of of bringing back these
characters in a way that does not feel
uh too convenient you know it doesn't
feel too forced like that
that's a thinking man's thinking person
star wars right there you really gotta
put the pieces together i'm not going to
give you any uh
treats or tricks the tricks and treats
today will be awarded
by my friend and star of the mandalorian
baby yoda
whoa you got him i got him and
supposedly he should
talk
oh my you know what he said he said you
get
three treats you get three robies
great job baby
all right that's enough now i said
that's enough hey don't you scream at
that child
he's very powerful this is so cute all
right
kimberly what do you got for me
okay well if eric's theory
was a thinking man's theory yes mine
is the woman's theory oh okay
now look i hate to talk business but i'm
gonna lean towards that because i think
what we know about disney and the star
wars
franchise is that they are very clever
about finding new ways to take my money
and i don't know what you're talking
about i
don't really like to spend a lot of
money on them
the fact remains is the fact remains is
that
rosario dawson is a big name and
to bring rosario dawson into season two
of the mandalorian i don't think that's
a happy
accident i mean yes i know she's kind of
been like a fan favorite people have
been trying to
talk her into doing or joining the the
franchise for years now
and she's finally joining but again i
don't think that's a happy accident i
think that is on purpose and i think
it's because
they're setting her up for her own
spin-off for
ahsoka and uh look
i personally think that ahsoka is a
character that fans want to see
brought to life and form of live action
i personally would love to see that um
and i think there's an opportunity here
for us to see
if we look at the age of rosario dawson
right she's 40 and she's looking
fantastic
but can we see an older ahsoka
character storyline in a spin-off from
the mandalorian season two abso freaking
lutely i think is the answer
uh and then last but not least ahsoka's
a badass character and i think we would
just all love to see her
especially rosario dawson who quite
frankly looks like her
real-life doppelganger play that role so
i'm very excited that's my pitch that's
my theory
my businesswoman theory i have spoken
that is
uh listen i'd love to do business i
think that is a great idea
we are buying that we are buying
anything with rosario dawson in it uh
including if they want to make a few
more clerks movies i would advise
against it but i'll go i'll still pay
for it
she can be in anything uh especially if
it's a
a show or we could see her every week
i'm all i'm down for that
i love uh you know the industry industry
is fascinating to me as well so i like
you know thinking about it logically
from an economic standpoint i love that
theory
but it doesn't matter what i think
kimberly ultimately it matters what the
child thinks so let's see what the child
says
wow that's that's gut wrenching content
right there
the child says you get three
treats as well three treats for your
idea quiet child quiet
we've got more show to do now three
treats for your theory as well
anything with rosario dawson's
automatically gonna get three treats for
me
uh and not a treat more child please
ah tom
you're bringing us home what do you got
for me all right hopefully uh baby yoda
likes this
um well you know what we know what
season two is gonna be about it's gonna
be about
the man amando and the child on the run
um with bounties on their heads
yes and that's going to bring out every
bounty hunter
pirate and scoundrel in the galaxy and
who's the biggest scoundrel out there
that we know
lando calrissian i think that
i think at some point maybe uh you know
they'll uh the child will be in danger
maybe maddow will be defeated or
like gone or something and i think that
uh the child will
will be defenseless as we see this like
shadowy figure walking up
and we're going to we're going to see
the feet approaching kind of like with
boba fett approaching um
fennec shan in season one and uh as the
feed come closer
baby oda looks up and we're just going
to hear hello
what do we have here i think that's how
they're going to introduce donald
glover's
uh version because as we know we don't
really know what he's been up to since
uh return of the jedi you know uh he's
he was on endor and then the next time
we see him he's on a sand crawler in
episode nine saying give leia beloved
right we don't really know what he's
been doing we don't even know
how many other robots he's been banging
in the meantime but these are the things
that we need to know
we can only hope this is why we watch
disney plus to find out these answers
yeah
i think every parent that signs up for a
disney plus subscription says i need
answers on the human to robot
intercourse
or i'm canceling and you know what
answer it for me across
all titles i want to find out what's
going on in lion guard
are they are they building robots yet
and what's going on with them
what's going on in uh in the frozen saga
is there an element of robot human love
that we can introduce to arendelle
i don't know i'm not sure tom wait wait
wait
ingratiate yourself with the new rock
stars universe by introducing
interspecies sex which is something that
they're gonna love in the comments
section
yeah i i um i would love to see
like whatever the explanation is to have
like billy d williams play
the character return of the jedi and
before
donald glover comes in like to be like i
took a de-aging potion or
like they just don't explain at all
because donald glover's impression was
awesome
i don't need it it was incredible they
should literally just do
the adam scott bradley cooper
explanation from wet hot american summer
and just be like wow you got a lot of
face surgery yes i did
okay that's it anyway that's all
and then never address it again uh it's
not up to me as we said it's always up
to the child here tom
and uh we don't we don't take it easy on
you just because this is your first show
so the child will be fair
wow wow just really
incredible content from the child right
now i mean they said that he had 27
i say he i'm not really sure they said
the child has
whoa the child just did a magic trick
you guys missed it uh sorry that we have
that off camera
he says uh you get three three treats as
well it's a clean three treat
sweet it's a three treat sweep thanks to
here
all right great uh so we're all knotted
up at threes and we're gonna move on to
our next question but first it's time
for me to talk about some products i'm
very passionate about
starting with our friends at blue chew
and for halloween we'll call it boo
chew thank you for sponsoring this quiet
first of all we we got to plug our
child's ears for this one okay
put you over there you can't hear this
because papa's about to say some
inappropriate things
thanks to our friends at blue chew for
sponsoring this episode we've talked
more times than it's healthy about the
fact that if there's a baby yoda that
means that probably someone that looks
like yoda
had sex at some point yes
insert myself i will ah
and wherever those two magical green
creatures were copulating
we hope it was confident confidently we
hope it was confidently because
we all want to be confident in the
bedroom the force is strong with you
ah right blue chews brings you the first
chewable with the same fda approved
active ingredients as viagra
and cialis because if you're too much of
a little baby boy
to swallow a pill we have to make it
easy on you so you can chew it
i don't want to swallow a pill to get a
boner i gotta chop chop it
grow up i mainline my bluetooth
you can take them anytime day or night
even on a full stomach go ahead eat a
full
meal and then take a bluetooth you
psychopath so you can be ready
whenever an opportunity arises i love to
eat a full rotisserie chicken
before i take a blue chew it's just
something i do
am i taking the blue chew for any reason
no i'm not i currently live with my
parents
okay the idea of having sex in the house
where my parents live
would honestly be fined by me at this
point i'm very desperate blue chew
is made in the usa it's prescribed
online by licensed physicians that's
great no rogue doctor is here
so you don't have to go to the doctor or
wait in line it's even cheaper than a
pharmacy
and they prepare it and they ship it
right to you in a discreet package and
again
boot you if you're listening you go
ahead and write that right on the box
this boy's going to boner town these are
blue chews
this is a one-way ticket to the polar
express
or should i say the boner express no
awkwardness you don't need to leave the
house
stay inside papa blue chew make a long
weekend of it put on the lord of the
rings on your hbo max and just
blue chew it out if you could benefit
from more confidence where it counts and
god i know i could
blue chew is the fast and easy way to
enhance your performance
nine out of ten adult yodas agree if you
gotta get it on
you gotta get it on with blue chew ah
right now we've got a special deal for
our listeners visit bluechew.com
and get your first shipment free when
you use our special promo code
rogue just pay five dollars shipping
that's five
bucks for a full staff all right again
that's b
l u e two dot com promo code rogue
to try it free if you can't pay five
dollars for a boner i don't know what to
tell you okay
i don't know what to tell you all right
next up
this isn't about boners but it is about
getting sprung
for shipping the holiday season is right
around the corner and this year
people will be buying more stuff online
than ever before
if you're an e-commerce seller that
wants to be ready to meet the demands of
a record-breaking online
shopping season let ship station help
shipstation helps online sellers of any
size get orders out quickly
save money on shipping and keep
customers happy and what do we always
say guys
you got to keep your customers happy
they'll get you the shipping rates
normally reserved for fortune 500
companies it's the fastest easiest and
most affordable way to manage and ship
your orders
manage orders and get your product to
happy customers and just a few clicks
click click click
i shipped it out to my customers i'm not
using some terrible service
15 clicks this one just a few they work
with all the major carriers and their
interface brings your products together
whether you're selling them
etsy amazon or your own website like my
personal website slugs
and more shipstation is the number one
choice of online sellers you'll ship
more in less time
with the best rates available and right
now rogue theory listeners can try
shipstation
free for 60 days when you use offer code
rogue
make sure your business is ready to meet
the demands of a massive online shopping
season get started at shipstation.com
today click on the microphone at the top
of the page
type in rogue that's shipstation.com
then enter the offer code rogue
shipstation.com make ship happen
it's winter time everyone and we're all
feeling like we can
take some liberties with our body let
some things grow out let some things
expand outward let some things
relax and i gotta tell you not okay
and i'm pleased to bring you the
breaking news of a new manscape product
alert that has nothing to do with that
as reported in all the industry trades
like variety magazine
entertainment weekly manscape just
released the weed whacker
nose and ear trimmer keep your ear and
nose hair
looking as great as the other clean
shaven parts of your body
if you're like me you like to resemble
an egyptian cat not a lot of hair but a
lot of mystery okay
some some very devious eyes sunken
features
and utterly hairless everywhere else
okay
nobody wants long booger bristles okay
other people agree
79 of partners polled say long nose here
is a major turn off and let me tell you
about the other 21
they're lying 100 of people agree
if you have long nose hair it shows you
don't care
about the relationship please for the
love of god take a weed whacker to your
nostrils
and i'm not gonna pull those bad boys
out by hand it's tedious
and it's painful and if you know me you
know i'm crying
seven days a week at this point there's
not a dry eyed evening for me i don't
need to make it worse by pulling out my
nose hairs
manually when there's a great company
like manscape manscape
is forever changing the grooming game
with their weed whacker the nose hair
and ear hair trimmer provides
proprietary skin safe technology
which prevents nicks and snags in those
delicate spots
the manscape weed whacker uses 360
degree rotary dual blade system with
contour designed to enhance
the trimming experience and who has not
thought to themselves
the trimming experience is pretty great
but if there was a way to enhance it i
would give them all of my money
it's waterproof so it's easy to use and
clean and it has a rechargeable battery
that lasts up to 90 minutes and as i
always remind you
if you are trimming your nose hair and
your ear hair for 90 minutes or
more than 15 minutes see a doctor
there's something wrong with you
it's time to upgrade your manscaped
routine with the weed whacker get 20
off and free shipping with the code
rogue theory at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
use the code
rogue theory what are you waiting for
go whack your weeds whack those weeds
yeah whack em whack-a-mole
okay now it's time to talk discord
guys we're gonna get to our discord
rogue theory but first i want to mention
on the sports thread of discord this
week i am introducing a football pick
contest saturday night i'm gonna make a
football pick video put it up on there
sometime sunday morning you guys will
have the option to pick against me or
pick with me
i'm gonna keep track of everyone's
scores and at the end of the season i'll
think of some prize there's got to be
some nerdy thing in my collection i can
give to one of you to satiate
your nerdy desires maybe it's a comic
book maybe it's a lock of my hair
maybe i just take a weed whacker carve
out my nose hairs put them in a ziploc
bag and give them to the winner that's
currency somewhere in belarus
nose hairs my nose hair is like gold in
belarus anyway
quick shout out to our patrons civil
unrest who won this week's discord rogue
theory contest on our patreon discord
server
their pitch for a mandalorian season 2
plot included both a fake
and real boba fett and a cameo from a
mysterious blue
lightsaber wielder i think i know who
that is so play along
in future rogue theories become a patron
by going to patreon.com
new rockstars and speaking of
lightsabers my spooky friends
you didn't think i was gonna leave the
halloween themes of this episode behind
did you
question two is positively ghoulish
season one of the mandalorian ended with
moff gideon surviving the tie fighter
crash and hacking his way out of the
ship with the darksaber
the ancient black lightsaber passed down
through generations of mandalorians
and last seen in the animated star wars
rebel series
being wielded by bogotan who will be
played by katie sakhoff in season
two so how did imperial officer moff
gideon get the dark saber tom
why don't you lead us off this time okay
well
um yeah so what do we know about the
darksaber so it was the first
lightsaber made by the first uh jedi
mandalorian tarvisla and when he died
his descendants from house vizsla who
ended up creating death watch
stole the saber and they use it as a
symbol of
power and leadership and whoever holds
it rules mandalore so
what if during the siege of mandalore
uh moth gideon actually stole it because
drumroll he is a mandalorian
not only that uh what if he's a
descendant
of house vizsla that would make him the
true heir to the throne
and the blade even though him using the
the dart saber as part of the empire is
total sacrilege um
but you know we've seen precedent of
this before like within rebels when
sabine wren
um you know was part of the empire for a
while so we know that the empire was
um you know was taking mandalorians and
moving them into the fold
and so and if this is true that actually
would
have really interesting symmetry with
din jaron's origins
you know here he is he's a foundling not
someone from mandalore who was raised in
the culture
and who now has become kind of the
pinnacle of what
the what a mandalorian really is and now
we have
maf gideon who if is true as is a
mandalorian with
claim to the throne and the darksaber
but he's someone who's betrayed his
people who've left them behind
and now it'll be a battle of who is the
real mandalorian
someone raised as a mandalorian or
someone who is
technically a mandalore but gave that
life up and i think that'd be really
interesting
too awesome that's a cool theory love it
yes that is a wonderful theory i uh
i mean i think that would be one of the
great twists if that ended up being true
i mean
i think people will be talking about
that forever uh i had to put the child
to sleep the child
needed to take a nap so instead the uh
the treats are going to be handed out
via this terrifying eye thing i found at
target
yes look how scary it is
it's like a steampunk eye of agamotto
yeah
wow terrifying the eye that sees all
says shut up uh
it says you get two treats for that
theory two
stinky treats no tricks so that brings
you to a total of five treats tom
wonderful kimberly follow that
i dare you
well i think i have a simpler theory
and uh you know the phrase drive it like
you stole it
yeah i think moth gideon is wielding the
dark saber
like he stole it off of
bocaton and she is alive
and she's a prisoner of war
but the new republic is allowing it
because
they want to see if they can get some
benefit off of her
you know this post-war like prisoner
exchange type thing
so that's my theory and i think
for the meantime he's like you know i
might as well use a sick sword
it's a pretty sick saber so i'm just
gonna
use it to my benefit yeah and
i have spoken all right this is the way
i this is the one anyone who quotes nick
nolte is good in my book
i think uh yeah i love it i
i love the idea of him just stealing it
being like
i better use this till i get in trouble
like it reminds me of like a teenage
like teenager stealing a boat or
something uh i like it
but it's not up to me it's up to you
it's up to this eye
the retina eye scanner and it's uh
it'll work don't worry okay
[Music]
oh it makes eye puns too which is the
fun thing
oh
i think with all the eye puns what that
meant is he's awarding you
two treats two treats as well two treats
two treats for you a total of five
treats as well eric no pressure but if
you don't get two treats here you'll be
firmly in the basement
oh my god what if i like the basement's
where jigsaw plays
oh no i don't like it down there not
with him um
all right well here's my thinking uh
giancarlo esposito has been
um you know hinting at the fact that
there's going to be some kind of
lightsaber duel
and i think one of the missteps of the
sequel series is that like
pretty much anyone can pick up a
lightsaber at any point who aren't jedi
like it's supposed to be like a sacred
thing
the only people pick up jedi are
supposed to be jedi themselves and i was
excited to see finn pick it up and
ignite it
but like he wasn't a jedi and they just
kind of like ignored
the importance of that moving on so i'm
thinking
that in order to have his hands and be
able to effectively wield this
uh i kind of want moff gideon to be a
former jedi uh or or at least a a jedi
youngling or a padawan who is at the
jedi temple at the moment of order 66
um kind of like as we've seen in jedi
fallen order
but he becomes an inquisitor right so
maybe he's like an inquisitor
who's working uh for the empire he's
someone who is
helping the empire hunt down other
former jedi
to to take them out and that's how he
gets to this moth position he's he's
rewarded with this position
for being such a valuable asset to
palpatine um
and it's possible that the dark saber
we're seeing uh it either could be
the dark saber it's also possible that
it's like a replica he built
uh from the dark saber uh using his own
black kyber crystal that he got from
ilum which is a plant they might be
visiting
but it could be the dark saber we'll see
which is true between those
but i think his goal is to start a new
sith order
uh that is in the name of palpatine even
though palpatine is believed to be dead
here i think one of his like
uh his dying wishes is to start a new
sith order and that
that is going to be the mission
overtaken by moff gideon and that is why
he wants the child
because he knows this child is force
sensitive and he's trying to track it
down because that's going to be
a keystone to whatever new school of
thought that he builds
are you saying he might turn the child
into a sith i think that's the goal yeah
i mean the kids he's very impressionable
he's only 50 years old
you know he could my god he could feed
his mind with all kinds of horrible
things his child just put
a chill in my spine
wait a second
oh oh no oh no
they're kissing oh god oh
no crossover we never thought we wanted
or needed eric
two treats for you too oh my god
disgusting well if the eye is a robot
that's actually pretty cool actually
more of that baby yoda is 15 or 50 but
the eye is only 17. so it is still
inappropriate
[Music]
okay that wasn't me that wasn't me all
right moving on we'll cut that out for
time i'm sure
wow here's our rook
leave it in all right here's our road
question guys great answers
we're all tied up at five you know me
i'm very uh
i'm very even keel about my rogue giving
until the end when i become cut
throat murderous evil
our road question james gunn tweeted
this week that he was given the freedom
to kill
any character he wanted by dc what if he
chose wonder woman
and warner brothers in the upcoming to
the suicide squad
he's like i actually just want your
bottom line to fail i kill wonder woman
uh if you could direct an installment of
any franchise and kill off any character
you'd like
who would it be and why i for me
um i would want to take over
uh a pixar film the toy story series
and i want to kill off all of humanity
in the toy story series so that it
becomes
the cars universe and now animatronic or
not animatronic uh
uh inanimate objects are actually alive
and they inherit the earth
they're all just every toys walking
around talking
there's just nothing stopping the toys
they're just toys
they're all toys i love it
well for mine here i need my wig for
mine because it's related it's related
to mine sorry hold on okay
wow welcome back john welcome back hello
so
um my theory of my theory yeah my my
idea is if i could direct
a john wick movie and kill
john wick because then his dog
would take up the revenge story and then
kill
everyone who killed him and it would not
be like air but it'd be
more like homeward bound where it's like
and yeah and we would watch the
who we watch his dog go on a spree to
get revenge on his owner
john wick a dog wow
i recently watched the latest terminator
movie
terminator dark fate and it got me
thinking
i'd love to direct a terminator
but kill off sarah connor like actually
kill off sarah connor i love her
character i actually think
that the latest movie i i sat there and
i was like why doesn't he just kill her
as well
he came all the way here to wherever
they
are mexico he goes all the way to mexico
to find john connor and the
and sarah's right there and he doesn't
even kill her so kill off sarah connor
and see
where that where that universe leads us
to
hmm sure yeah interesting i like that
i like all three of them the correct
answer unfortunately was you kill waldo
from the where's waldo books so then it
just becomes
where's and it's an existential search
to find meaning in anything
everyone's just standing around no i'm
kidding of course the correct answer is
kill all humans so the toys
rule the world toy story eric voss is
our winner eric congratulations what is
your
wish your victory wish for us to do
today on the show
oh uh in the spirit of halloween i want
all of us to do
our evil laughter uh and just like
really you know what this is our last
one before the election so
just get out all the rage and evil dark
spirits just
vent them into the cosmos
and get it out of our system so
hopefully we can enter this new era
pure and without any toxicity everyone
ready
three two one
the child
this is my son the child this is his
boyfriend the evil eye
i want to thank our guests tom michelson
kimberly trung eric voss don't forget to
subscribe to the rogue theory podcast
feed and stay tuned to the youtube
channel for this and other shows follow
us on twitter at new rockstars
follow these find people at their
twitter handles displayed below
follow me at tommy peck told i'm on all
major dating apps
follow me trick or treat everyone happy
halloween
and again go to uh newrockstarsmerch.com
check out
for this kind of shirt and all the other
kinds of cool stuff play a trick on your
credit card and
treat yourself to some merch good night
everybody good night
[Music]
you